[Musique]
l'un des principaux atouts de la ville
de saint jean de losne c'est sa position
géographique stratégique ici à
l'embranchement entre d'un côté le canal
de bourgogne vers la scène et le bassin
parisien et de l'autre la saône vers le
rhône et la méditerranée
cette position lui a permis de
développer une importante activité
économique activité de location de
bateaux par exemple et c'est ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui
activité tellement importante que saint
jean donne est devenu aujourd'hui le
premier pôle de plaisance intérieur en
france en les blanches
on verra une bonjour bonjour manuel on
va faire un tour installez-vous
[Musique]
est ce qu'on arrive à mettre à profit
des périodes de confinement comme ça ou
de crise pour pour faire autre chose
quand les touristes se sont pas là oui
parce que pendant la période hivernale
ont fait le gros entretien sur les
bateaux pour pouvoir redémarrer la
saison sur de bonnes bases
donc ça nous a permis d'avancer sur le
travail des bateaux les touristes qui
viennent là ils sont ils sont contents
ils attendaient avec impatience de
reprendre les vacances un produit qui
s'adapte particulièrement bien puisque
là on est à l'écart de la foule
chacun gère ses vacances comme il le
conçoit donc ils peuvent se retrouver en
famille
donc on a vraiment un produit que
l'idéal cette période d'après crise
et on peut arriver ici est complètement
novice et prendre des commandes du
bateau
oui alors ça c'est le gros avantage
injustement de notre activité c'est de
pouvoir louer un bateau sans permis sur
l'ensemble des voies navigables en
france et en europe
et si en bourgogne franche comté on est
vraiment bien lotis puisque là ici on
est sur la saône donc on a le choix de
navigation du canal comme le canal de
bourgogne qui est juste là derrière nous
ou alors sur la saône ou encore un peu
plus loin sur aux lionnes on a vraiment
un bel éventail de voies navigables ici
en bourgogne franche comté
le vent soufflera
écoulée
[Musique]
il prend la mer
c'est la mer
il prend l'or
[Musique]
elle m'a pris ou
andy on sort d'une période un peu
compliquée confinement restrictions
c'est quelque chose qui vous ai manqué
de peu de pouvoir embarquer d'aller
faire un tour
alors oui tout à fait c'est on passe de
très bons moments sur sur les péniches
avec l'équipe de l'aube donc avec c'est
des choses qui manquent mais
heureusement on a pu entre les
confinements déjà en profiter et puis
continuer de naviguer de profiter de ce
genre de moments assez extraordinaire
avec les amis on est vraiment dans la
liberté à la nature et puis ça qu'on a
développé des des événements faire des
week-ends à thème yoga danse directement
sur le bateau en pleine nature sur sur
l'eau avec cdd moment hors du temps
on retrouve la liberté
tout en étant justement en vase clos
rien qu'entre nous donc c'est quelque
chose qui est en plus ultra d'altérer
situation évoque le navire dans ce
secteur-là aussi et cette fois au propre
comme au figuré l'activité a donc repris
sa vitesse de croisière